welcome everybody
thank you for joining us today for a
hybrid seminar sponsored by the program
on refugees forces placement and
humanitarian responses at the macmillan
my name is catherine panderbrick i am
professor of anthropology health and
global affairs at yale and today i have
the pleasure of introducing and hosting
our speaker
let me introduce you briefly to
professor michael pleuse
he
is professor in developmental psychology
at queen mary university of london so
obviously joins us here from the uk for
a hybrid seminar he came to the field of
psychology after training in chemistry
music and therefore has a very
interesting personal and scientific
background to offer us today
he is
very well known internationally for his
work on environmental sensitivity
which anchors in science and notion that
some people are more affected by the
very same experience for example stress
than others because they are more
sensitive to environmental conditions
and that sensitivity shapes our human
development over the life course as he
shows in his work
he's also known for
work on positive development and
resilience evaluating interventions
aimed to promote well-being in children
and adults
and he leads research on mental health
in humanitarian crisis which is where in
the area in which our work intersect and
how i came to know him
as a very generous a highly productive
scholar interested in interdisciplinary
work and transnational collaborations
so uh it's really my pleasure to
introduce him to you today he'll talk
about the research that he has led on
mental health of syrian refugee children
uh living in precarious conditions in
lebanon
and his and the work he has led on
phone-based psychological therapy in
lebanon
the title of this is you know is really
a great uh pleasure to welcome him the
title of his talk today is prevalence
predictors and treatment of mental
health problems in syrian refugee
children uh before we start please know
that dr pluis welcomes questions
clarifications or concerns during this
presentation so if you have any uh
please put that in a chat or raise your
hand and we'll be able to munch him
to stop and respond to you as he
talks to us
so
welcome michael and it's a great
pleasure to hand over to you thank you
for joining us today
well thank you very much for the kind
introduction and it's really great to be
here uh
i've met katherine quite a while ago uh
when
i was at the very beginning of
developing this idea so it's fantastic
to be able to be here and to
share where we've been what we've
managed to do over the last few years so
i wish i was there in person i was
in my music days oh actually
i was at yale
once
but
and i remember it was it's really a
wonderful beautiful place
so let me start with um
giving an overview of what what i'd like
to cover today so there's quite a few
things um i'd like to first give a
background the syrian
context and then i'll introduce the
biopath study and several findings so i
will talk about the prevalence
predictors of mental health problems
i will then talk about risk and
resilience factors and the research
we've done on that then also talk about
the dynamic nature of resilience looking
at the longitudinal analysis
and then have some findings on the
biological embedding of war exposure
and then
i'll talk about the tc test study this
is about a phone delivered psychological
intervention
i'll present some findings on the
efficacy of bone delivered treatment as
well as the feasibility and
acceptability of phone delivered
treatment
and then i'll discuss those findings um
i will discuss them as i present some of
them but i'll be happy to be interrupted
um
and then i'll try to bring everything
together in this discussion and then
have some practical implications at the
very end
i'd like to start however
with uh hearing from you
and i prepared some questions on mental
media obviously you're all experts but
i'd like to know from you
how many refugees you think that they
are currently across the world and so if
you go on mentee.com
and then to that code then you can
enter your estimate of what you think
how many refugee children we have today
across the world
so that can just be a wild guess
to the best of your knowledge
i'll have some more questions after that
so
it's worth
logging in
okay you can still enter that but um
i think most of the answers
are in the in the right area so um the
most recent data suggests that there are
about 85 085 million refugees in the
world half of which
are children so
it is between 40 and 45 million so you
got that right um so that was an easy
question
the next question
is a bit might be a bit more challenging
and uh because it's not
not that
obvious necessarily
so out of these children how many do you
think are suffering from mental health
problems
in percentage
what's your guess
now we get a bit more of a range here
but the maturity suggests 50 percent
that is um
i think the whole range that we see
represented here is supported by the
evidence and i'll talk a bit more about
that
and 50 is relatively high
[Music]
okay and then the last question
is the one regarding treatment how many
of these children that have problems
receive mental health treatments
so how many of the refugee children
that actually have mental health
problems
end up receiving mental health treatment
what's your best guess
okay so
yes that looks that looks about right
um we have quite a few refugee children
that have mental health problems
and a very small
number of children actually receive help
that they need
great so uh
good responses
and uh i will provide data on all these
questions today
and
um
yes so uh you were
quite correct in that assessment
um
some background on the syrian refugee
crisis
so i'm not going to go in great detail
because most of you will be very
familiar with this but this is a long
uh ongoing conflict so it's it's already
10 years that this has been going on and
it started with
a conflict between the syrian government
and a few rebel groups
and then turned into a very very
complex proxy war
involving various parties and has been
in the news on and off not so much
recently but the conflict is still
ongoing although it's not the same
as it used to be
um
the consequences are substantial so
estimates
uh
talk about
half a million of deaths
and many refugees
so the 6.2 million syrians that are
displaced within
syria don't often hear about those we
hear mostly about those externally
displaced which is about 5.6 million
and when we look at those so the most
recent numbers according to unhcr which
these are the registered
refugees they're more refugees than
those that are registered but they're
5.6 million persons of concern so these
are registered with unhcr and most of
them are in turkey
and then followed by lebanon jordan
iraq egypt and as well some in north
africa
i think what's important to
consider
is that most of the refugees remain in
the middle east and that's obviously
true of most refugee
settings
that refugees tend to well be displaced
within their country and then
end up in neighboring countries although
there's how in particular in europe
there has been
a lot of debates and a lot of uh
at the moment again with uh the
situation in belarus and poland with
refugees coming over to europe but
actually most of them are in the middle
east and it's only a small proportion of
the refugees that have fled to europe
importantly for us for for my work is
that 50 of the syrian refugees are
children
and
they are significantly affected by the
crisis
one important aspect is that they are
often not
often don't have access to school and
that's as well the the case with our
sample so in our sample
um
with
families that have been in lebanon for
several years
about 40 of the children have access to
school
and the others not even though they are
in a you know in a
relatively stable refugee environment
uh what do we know about the mental
health of syrian refugee children well
there are more studies more recently and
they actually suggest that there's
a quite a range so when you look at ptsd
the prevalence rates range from 10 or 11
to 45
similarly for anxiety between about 10
to 50 percent you see the same with
depression
between 12 to 2 48
so this suggests that there is a wide
variability in those prevalence
estimates
so we need to do more to find out what's
it what is actually the number
that we're looking at
and there is likely a significant need
for mental health treatment in syrian
refugee children and i'll report more on
that later
so
it's obviously important to do research
in order to understand the mental health
problems as well as the needs of syrian
refugee children
but also and that's what we try to do is
to identify the specific factors and
processes that are involved in risk and
resilience of these children and that's
important because it would inform
programs as well as interventions
and
while we know quite a bit about adverse
events and
negative outcomes it's also important to
focus on protective factors because it
might be easier to or more feasible to
strengthen
protective factors than prevent adverse
situations from happening because if
there is a conflict is ongoing we can't
resolve the conflict but we can
strengthen what you know the protective
factors amongst those children and
families
and
hopefully you know that sort of research
would help to also allocate resources to
those interventions and services where
they're most likely to benefit
the refugee children
the three specific factors
that are important that i think are
important to consider in that sort of
research and the first one is
developmental
that development occurs in nested
contexts as proposed by yuri
bronfenbrenner in his ecological systems
theory
so when we look at an individual
developing we always need to consider
the developmental context of that
individual
and bronfenbrenner suggested that
an individual is nested within a whole
range of different systems
so most importantly would be the
microsystems this is the immediate
context of the child so that would be
the family peers the school environment
but these environments are further
influenced by the availability of
services
on the exorcism but also by cultural
facts in the macro system so if you want
to understand the development of the
individual we have to also consider all
these different systems that
represent the context within the which
the child is developing but also the
factors that then have an impact on the
context within the child is developing
so that's really important another
important consideration is that we can
look at multiple levels of analysis
so in psychology which is my background
we often look at the behavioral we ask
people to complete questionnaires or we
interview them
but in order to really understand
the pathways across different levels of
analysis we also need to look at the
neurological level at the biochemical
level or at the molecular level at the
far end
of extremes at the genetic level
and ideally we do all of that to
understand
how they how they all influence each
other
and whether the behavior reflects what
happens on the biological level and so
forth
and the last point i already alluded to
is that it's important to
not just look at the absence of disease
but also at the presence of positive
outcomes
so there has been a lot of work that
would focus on the negative effects of
risk factors and maladaptive outcomes
and we need to do more work to also look
at protective factors and the positive
effects on adaptive outcomes obviously
some work has been done on that but i
think it's really important to not just
not forget that health is more than just
the absence of disease
so we try to do all of that in the
biopath study
and the biopath study is a collaboration
between
myself and colleagues at queen mary
university of london and early chrome
and colleagues at iraq
in lebanon and then our fieldwork
partner was metza de monde
and it was funded by nichd
so
the focus of the study is really looking
at individual differences in response to
war and displacement we know that
millions of children are affected by war
and displacement that many of them
develop psychological problems
however
some do not develop psychological
problems they seem to be resilient
and this study is really trying to
understand the biological underpinnings
of such individual differences in
response to
war and displacement
taking into account multiple settings as
i mentioned with the biological systems
theory
looking at the family environment school
environment the community the
neighborhood availability of services
but also looking across multiple levels
of analysis
so looking at the environmental factors
social but also psychological
neuroendocrine epigenetic and genetic
factors
and then we look at both risk and
protective factors both adaptive and
maladaptive outcomes
i will not present
findings about the adaptive outcomes
today and we're not going to talk about
well-being outcomes mostly we'll talk
about mental health outcomes but we will
consider both risk and protective
factors
and an important aspect of this study is
it's a longitudinal design it's very
difficult to do longitudinal research in
these settings or it's very challenging
to do any research in these settings uh
but longitudinal research is
particularly
challenging
so that's why many of the studies
are cross-sectional and
um when i mentioned all these these
points uh catherine obviously collected
data where she did all of those things
as well and it's one of the few uh
studies that have achieved a long-term
study looking at multiple levels of
analysis and settings
the study design is that basically we
were interested in war explosion
displacement and how it has an impact on
both risk and resilience
captured with psychological and
biological outcomes
that's the main question then you want
to understand how
environmental risk and protective
factors outside of war explosion
displacement as well as genetic factors
also have an impact
on these outcomes and how they moderate
the impact that war exposure has on
these outcomes
and then an important aspect of the
study is to see whether the
impact of environmental risk factors war
exposure and genes
are mediated through
dna methylation
and impacted by genetic factors and
further enormous risk factors on those
outcomes so that's a baseline and then
we look at all those factors again 12
months later in the follow-up assessment
we did that
with a sample of
close to 1 600 families
so these are the children plus their
primary caregivers so the total sample
is there for about it's more than three
thousand the age range that we aimed for
is between eight to sixteen years
and we collected that data in end of
2017 early 2018 and then a year later we
did a follow-up assessment and
we were aiming for
about two-thirds of the study of the
sample that's what we expected we would
be able to get so we didn't actually
have the funding to collect data from
more we would have been able to collect
a bit more than these
but there is about a mobility of
about two-thirds so within a year a
third of the refugees tend to move on
a little bit about the sample that we
collected so an important point is that
our recruitment rate was about 70
that means
70 percent of all the families that we
approached for inclusion in this study
said yes
so that suggests
that our sample is is sort of
representative of the refugee population
where we recruit it from and i'll share
a bit more details about
the location
we ended up with a fairly
balanced gender splits between female
and male children
the age range
ended up between 6 to 19
years of age we aimed for a
broad
age range because we wanted to look at
developmental questions as well we knew
we it would be very difficult to have
more than two waves of data collection
so we did sort of a compromise having a
wide age range and then collecting data
along generally once at a time two time
points which allows us to look at
longitudinal questions and taking the
developmental age
of children into account as well
most of them are syrian not surprisingly
the caregiver was in most cases uh the
mother
and in a small
small number of fathers
the measures uh we collected a lot of
different measures so this is just a
very simple summary so we basically
correct uh collected data on child and
from child and caregiver we collected
data on their psychopathology
on their well-being and then a wide
range
of protective and risk factors
across the individual
the social environment and the
the the wider social environment
and an important feature is that we also
collect the biological samples so we
have saliva that we collected for
genetic analysis and epigenetic analysis
both of these are genome-wide so we
we have genome-wide genetic data and
epigenetic data so that's dna
methylation
and we also collected hair samples to
look at three
neuroendocrine variables so most
importantly the cortisol
i have a couple of clarification
questions hi this is erasio hello good
to see you
nice to see you too um the genetic data
you collect the only on the children or
also the parents
and it's only the children so the
biological data is only from from the
children
and any reason why you only did 6 to 19
rather than younger children
the reason is that we collected
data from the children and they needed
to be able to respond
basically to complete
the data collection the data was not
collected
in written form it was all in interview
but the the main reason is that we
wanted to
ensure that our measures would be
suitable for for that age of children so
if he
wanted to collect data from younger
children we probably would have to use
different measures for them yeah
so one of the challenges is to find
measures that work for an age range
between eight
uh and and eighteen
okay we can talk about it at some point
but go ahead
yeah great thank you
okay the location
uh you will probably know where uh
lebanon is based the important thing is
that lebanon is pretty much surrounded
by syria
uh as you can see so that's one of the
reasons why many syrian refugees ended
up in lebanon
within lebanon
we collected data which actually is is a
fairly small country
we collected all of our data in the west
picar valley so this is
about an hour
an hour and a half
away from beirut
uh by car
and some of the settlements are fairly
close to syria so maybe just a 10-minute
drive from the syrian border
and we collected data from about 80
different refugee settlements
and here is an example of one of those
refugee settlements these are all
informal settlements and relatively
small settlements
here is a
typical one you can see they have
tented structures they have satellite
dishes on them so they've been living
there for some of them for for several
years already
but it's still it's still a difficult
life um even though they have
relatively solid tinted structures it
does rain and it does snow in this
region and it's it's quite difficult
living there
and here is uh
the team that collected data at wave one
so we had 20 field workers uh two
different teams that went from
settlement to settlement
all the data was collected uh in
interviews
and we used tablets to do so so the
interviewer was
asking all the questionnaire questions
directly to the child in arabic
and then was recording that in the
tablets then we're uploading the data
the same day onto the service so we
basically had real-time data we always
knew at the end of the day what data has
been collected and were able to look at
that data
at the same time as the child was
interviewed another member of the team
was interviewing the caregiver in a
different
section of the tent or outside which is
the case here
and
i have a little video
that provides a bit more of the context
so let me share that so this the sound
is not very loud but
the it's in arabic
so i don't know how many of you speak
arabic i don't
um
so that it's translated into english so
you can read at the bottom of the sound
is not very loud but hopefully you'll
get a bit of the context of the study
[Music]
it
[Music]
a
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
all right i hope you got a little bit of
a flavor
of the data collection
um
it was quite challenging to get this
study uh approved by all the different
ethics
committees um not so much in the uk but
in lebanon so it took quite a while to
get this um through and it was quite
challenging collecting the data but the
team did an excellent job and we managed
to collect
i would say
very high quality data on a large sample
so i will i will share some of these
findings much of that is
still in the progress so these are
papers none of none of those papers are
published yet but they're either
submitted in uh on the review or they um
are to be submitted very soon so
these are still sort of uh
somewhat preliminary findings in some
cases um
the first findings i want to present is
about mental health needs and treatment
and
the research question that we want to
address with this analysis is the
following we wanted to look at what is
the prevalence of mental health problems
amongst our sample of syrian refugee
children
we wanted to look at what are the main
predictors of those mental health
problems
we also wanted to look at what is the
perceived need for treatment of syrian
refugee children and we asked the
children as well as the caregivers
whether they think their child
would need
treatment of mental health problems
and the last question we then also
wanted to look at what are common
barriers to available mental health
services asking
the families whether they are aware of
any services available to them and
whether they would use them and if not
why not
this particular paper is the work of my
postdocs uh fiona machine and claudine
bietzolli
so a little bit about the measures here
so we used self established self-report
scales to measure mental health of
depression we used to see esd for
anxiety we used to scare both of those
were shortened to reduce the burden of a
data collection
they were reduced based on very
carefully conducted pilot studies
so we've
basically collected data on all of the
items and then random factor analysis
and reduce them
to
shorten them the ptsd scale was the full
scale and externalizing problems was the
sdq items but we added some additional
items that we created based on dsm-5 for
conduct disorder and odd
and
all those were on based on child
reporting step extern externalizing
problems when we collected externalizing
problems based on child reports in pilot
studies
that data was not very reliable so
the other data seemed to be more
reliable on child report but
externalizing problems was based on care
giver reports
in addition we conducted clinical
interviews in a sub-sample
with the mini kid
and that was a sub-sample of 134
children
that were at different levels of risk in
order to create a representative
sample
that represents the total sample
so we conduct those interviews
in arabic
with the help of a local clinical
psychologist and two trained counselors
either in the clinic
or in settlements
and then all those cases were discussed
with the clinical supervisor before
agreeing on a diagnosis
and here are the findings
so we have basically data on from
clinical assessments in a sub-sample of
134 children
we then created cut-off scores based on
that sample that we apply to the rest of
the example
based on child self-report and caregiver
report but we also as a third option we
ask the caregivers after asking them to
complete um their self-report about
their own mental health we ask them
what do you think your child is
suffering from those problems as well
so and what we got
here
is
the clinical sample
we got relatively high
levels but within the margins that all
of you indicated at the very beginning
so post-traumatic stress disorder was
about 40
based on clinical interviews
externalizing problems around 27
depression around 20 anxiety disorders
was very high with close to 50 percent
and
what is interesting is that adhd
is not much higher than we would expect
um
in non-refugee samples
um so it's particularly depression
uh ptsd
and anxiety disorders and externalizing
those that are particularly higher than
it would be in other child samples
when we based on those findings then
created cut-off scores for our
other measures and applied it to the
whole sample
we basically found the same thing which
is not surprising given that the cutoffs
are based on the clinical sample but
that's basically replicated across the
whole sample
actually the anxiety disorder measure
was normally distributed and
we were very cautious using the anxiety
measure here
um because we we don't think it's a good
measure
it's not a good
measure to use to indicate uh mental
health problems
in this particular um sample the same
measure that we used with our cartels
has been used by our colleagues
in turkey in a different in the syrian
refugee sample living in istanbul and
they found much lower prevalence rates
and i think that our sample is of
particular high vulnerability
so the third finding is that we ask
caregivers to uh to report in what they
think whether their child needs help and
interestingly we find that
it's fairly
similar to a
cut-off scores and clinical interviews
so 35 percent of the caregivers thought
that their child needs help for ptsd
or has significant ptsd problems and
with depression it was a little bit
higher than the others with anxiety so
it's a bit a little bit lower we only
ask them in relation to ptsd depression
and anxiety
i think the most important yes
sorry if it's okay to jump in i just
have a question on that so for the
caregiver reports are these um whether
they think that their child is
experiencing this or whether
they i guess both think their child is
experiencing this and
should receive professional care
um yes i have to specify that we this
particular question was whether their
child has is suffering from those
problems
basically we we've
the the caregivers
completed their own ptsd measure
once they completed their own ptsd
measure they were interviewed about that
they were also asked is
any other member in your family
suffering from those problems is your
child suffering from problems like that
and then in a consequent question we ask
them about whether the child needs help
so that's why i confuse those things but
yeah so they were always asked
the data that you see here is when they
were asked whether their child is
suffering from similar problems
as the ones that caregiver just reported
i think the main thing to take away from
this scale from this table here is that
when we look at any mental health
problem
we look at
prevalence rates close to 60
so very high
initially we looked at
the self-report scales and we thought
maybe that's going to be lower once we
look at the clinical
uh interview data but even with clinical
interviews the individual interviews
conducted by mental health
by trained people
we get very similar scores so a very
high prevalence
of mental health
problems the next one is finding is
looking at comorbidity and i don't want
to say too much about that but this is
these are the co-mobility findings in
the clinical sample right so we have the
same as well in with the self-report
data
and findings look very similar
and the main message here is as would be
expected
co-mobility is the norm so in almost
90 percent of the cases
we have comorbidity
usually involving ptsd and something
else
sir do you mind if i just ask quickly uh
what the rates in the previous table
were in turkey and whether you
think oh in turkey yeah and also whether
you think that the discrepancies
indicate um
differences in
prior experiences before arriving to the
country or because of environmental
factors um or just like the income of
that family
yes so i don't i don't remember the
exact numbers but where we found
about 50
of children are above the cut-off scores
for anxiety
in the turkish sample it was
i think between five and ten percent
so significantly lower
and we think so we this is still
something that we have to look at
but we think that our sample probably
you know are living in very much more
difficult uh context
and may have more of a
higher war exposure but we haven't
compared that so i can't say whether
that's the case but what seems to be the
case is that
the context that they're living in right
now
might be much more challenging
in lebanon than in turkey yeah i mean
and that might explain some of that
that that's certainly been my
understanding as someone that has done
work in turkey and seen the statistics
in lebanon it's the conditions are way
worse but then of course i you know
you're always curious about
uh
you understand that a lot of that is
from the current environmental
circumstances but then you also wonder
how much of this also relates to the
prior circumstances thank you
sure well actually my next slide
addresses some of those questions
because we looked at the predictors and
that's a busy table so um i just wanted
to communicate the main message here so
we looked at demographic factors war
events perceived refugee environment is
the quality of the current environment
that includes
access to facilities living conditions
um
the social context within the family in
the community so a whole range of
different factors this is a measure that
we created from scratch
based on various pilot studies
and we also looked at child
caregiver child relationship and
caregiver mental health symptoms
and what you can see is that war events
are important they predict all the
outcomes that we looked at
but actually the strongest predictor was
the current environment
and
so
the higher the score the higher the
quality of the of the environment so
that's why you see the negative
relationships here
but the effects of the current
environment is
is
a much higher than that of war events
an important predictor was also
maltreatment in the family
and
also caregiver mental health problems
michael
yeah could i could i ask you a question
until we find out how to get this person
on on my top um
and i know you may be able to say that
but i'm just going to ask it quickly the
um my treatment question is obviously an
extremely sensitive question to ask to
families and caregivers
so and this one that's really
interesting to many scholars can you
just elaborate a little bit about how
you get these data
so this is the icast measure that we
used
and we
um so ali karam who who is the co-pi on
the study
they've used that same measure in
previous studies
in similar samples so we knew a little
bit from their experience what questions
would be more acceptable with less
and we excluded certain questions that
would be unethical to ask
but i think
important
to
maybe realize here is that
relatively harsh parenting is much more
accepted
in that cultural context than compared
to here
so i did it often felt that neither the
child the children or the parents
wouldn't necessarily find it unusual to
report some of the behaviors that we
would find a bit more alarming here
maybe you could continue our question if
the room is going to try and come
through the chat virus various people
yes so then any a very important finding
is when we ask them the caregivers
whether they are interested in receiving
mental health treatment for their child
that was only 25
or 25.6
so
there's quite a disparity between the
men the children that seem to be at risk
of men significant mental health
problems and
the caregivers that felt that their
child would benefit from treatment
so we then asked them about the
awareness of services and and less than
50 were aware of any services
we asked them whether they've used any
and
only very few used any of the available
services the majority of services used
were those delivered in the communities
and then we ask them about reasons why
they are not using services most of them
said well they don't have a need for
treatment and for those that had a need
for treatment but still did not use them
the reasons were that they were not
aware of services or didn't know did not
know how to access them thought that
they were too expensive there were
transport issues
lebanon doesn't really have public
transport so that's a big challenge
and then a few people also mentioned
stigma
and security issues
so i have quite a few other findings to
um
to share so i like to move on but i'll
come back to some of those findings and
what they could mean
so the second set of
stuff of
actually two studies is looking at risk
and resilience and the question that we
were addressing here is firstly you
wanted to see how many syrian refugee
children could we consider as resilient
within that sample second question what
factors differentiates the resilient
children from those at risk
and the third question how does
resilience change over time and what
predicts those changes
and then what is the directionality of
detected associations when looking at
the development of resilience over time
and this is the work conducted by my phd
student cassandra popper who is in the
process of writing up all these findings
so the first question
is
what is resilience and how do we define
resilience lots of people define
resilience in different ways so we stuck
to a fairly simple
definition resilience is positive
development despite diversity so
basically refugee children that
experienced war
but did not develop mental health
problems that's our definition of
resilience
and we did that
across multiple dimensions so many
studies that look at resilience may only
look at depression or only look at ptsd
but we said a resilient child is one
that is below the cutoffs of these three
outcomes here below depression ptsd and
externalizing problems
and that was about 20 of the sample
so 20 were below these three cut-offs we
didn't consider anxiety because anxiety
didn't differentiate well between risk
and resilience
if a child was above one or more
cut-offs they were considered in the
risk at risk group and that was the
remaining 80 percent
so we had about 20 percent that we
considered resilient
and 80 at risk for mental health
problems
in the next step we looked at war
exposure
and
uh you can work exposure was measured
with a
a scale with 25 items so usually that's
used by just summing up all those
different war events in the total scale
but we wanted to look more carefully at
war exposure and we also in addition to
the total score looked at sort of the
different types
that children experience the typical
different types of war exposure that
they had
so there was a small
number of children that didn't report
any poor exposure
importantly as well war exposure was
based on child report and caregiver
report if any of them reported at all
events
then we considered them
as has happened so it was the
combination of child and caregiver
report
so there was
some children predominantly experienced
bombardment but not any of the others so
they were in that theoretical group of
bombardments and um
the most most severe was bodily harm
basically if children experience bodily
harm they experienced most of the other
events as well
we created those different groupings
in order to match children uh based on
their war exposure
so we matched
we we selected the resilient children
all of the resilient children we try to
match each of these children with one
that is at
risk so is in the risk group but has
similar war exposure so we match them
for each resilient child we try to find
one child that has the same total score
in war exposure but also the same
theoretical group so
for example this child here is in a
resilient group
and experienced bodily harm and has a
fairly high score we matched that child
with another child that is in risk group
that has
high that has mental health problems and
is similar for exposure
in order to look at
individual differences and what predicts
why are some children that have the same
more exposure than children
that have mental health problems
why do they not have mental health
problems
so then we conducted logistic
regressions to identify the factors that
differentiate between
risk and resilience so basically
we have children that have identical war
exposure some children developed
mental health problems
others did not
and we wanted to see what factors
differentiate between the two
and so we looked at a whole range of
factors as you can see here
so these are the odds ratios
the
the
we all we conducted individual models
for each of these um
predictors but then also combine them
and correct it for multiple corrections
so the the dark blue ones are the ones
that survive correction corrections i'll
only have a look at those so self-esteem
was one of them
self-esteem might be a correlate of
good mental health right so we don't
really say with this analysis whether
this is a correlate or a predictor it's
just something that differentiates this
group children in the resilience group
tend to have higher self-esteem
children in the risk group tend to have
caregivers
with more ptsd problems
experience more child moral treatments
have caregivers with high depression
experience more loneliness and also have
higher scores and environmental
sensitivity this is a temperament rate
that reflects heightened sensitivity to
the environment both negative and
positive experiences
so this is what we found and then
the next
study we wanted to look at the change in
resilience over time
and this is quite a busy figure here
but basically we have the baseline
and we have the follow-up
data
at baseline that's just what i showed
you 20
are in the resilience group and the vein
remaining 80 in the high risk group
when we look at those groupings again at
the follow-up
we do see that now at the follow-up
there's 30 in the resilient group
and about 66
in the high risk group however
there is considerable change over time
there is a group
that is
stable stably resilient
but there is
a significance about half of the
children that are in the resilient group
at wave one are no longer in the
resilient group at wave two so that
means they should they had a significant
increase in mental health problems and
we defined that at least a 20
change in one of the mental health
outcomes so they are above
at least one cut-off and at least 20
percent change so that it's not just a
minimal change just slightly above the
cut-off these are significant changes on
average the change that we saw is 40
increase so michael i have another
question to try to understand this
picture
uh so the
definitional risk here
is if they've been exposed to us to work
now the definition of risk here is being
above at least one of the cut-offs of
our three mental health outcomes
so
michael can i ask you a question as well
and you also have a question in the chat
um
you know we've discussed that
given that our work for instance is
actually measuring resilience as opposed
to assuming it's de facto from the
presence or absence of mental health
symptoms
there is a reason why you did not do
that and that's probably because you
work in a younger age group
but
i'm just wondering why you call them
resilient and risk in term instead of
calling them just low risk and high risk
in other words why do you label
them resilient resilient children
because that is not measuring resilience
is measuring the absence of symptoms
yes so
um
so these are all valid points so
we refer to them as resilient
when we match them on the war exposure
because they had war exposure but they
did not develop mental health problems
in the current analysis actually we talk
about low and high risk because
they're not matched with war exposure
here we just look at low basically low
mental health and high mental health
but the word exposure definition refers
to
events prior to the baseline
yes
and could it be that
the the children that
go from
blue to pink
is because they're experiencing new
so it's not much driven by their
resilience but or changing in resilience
but
additional
environmental factors
like
yeah
exactly
exactly that's that's an important
it's important to realize that even
though maybe when we look at war
exposures some children seem to be
resilient the context of displacement
itself leads to new trauma and
even though a child might have been
resilient at one point doesn't
necessarily mean that child will remain
resilient or will remain at low risk of
mental health even in that context of
displacement we see changes most of that
change though is from children being at
higher risk
to no longer be at higher risk but it's
really a dynamic
development over time
where the majority of children don't
really change
but some children change but not only
from
higher risk to low risk but also from
lower risk to high risk and i think
that's an important message
that
we don't
think that once we measure mental health
and it's low then it will stay like that
because they're living in a very
challenging context where they
experience new trauma as well that there
is considerable change we actually
looked in that paper we look up the
predictors for all of these different
groups and i just mentioned some of the
stable high and stable low so they're
fairly similar to what i showed earlier
so it is caregiver mental health it's
maltreatment
is its
aspects of the family environment such
as parent-child conflict or maternal
acceptance and then individual factors
such as sensitivity being higher in
those at higher risk and self-esteem
being higher in those that are
in the low-risk group
michael you have two questions so i just
want to reiterate it's really important
to know that trajectories are malleable
over time and that's why intervention is
um
you know
really important at that kind of age
group so thank you for for that message
uh you have two questions if i can ask
you quickly a candice has a question
on how is war events measured in these
analyses
and you have another question from the
person in the room
um on the symptomology when they
reported symptomology of mental
illnesses whether
uh they were
i think you answered that where
caregiver educate educated where
caregiver told about the kind of
symptomatic of the mental illness prior
to the interview or were they just
profit the questions so one on the
measurement of war events and the other
on the
kind of
contacts information you gave caregivers
before they answered
sure questions on mental health
so war events were measured with the war
events questionnaire by
our collaborator eli karam he's
that has been developed for the middle
east
uh and has been used previously and it's
basically 25 items that you can sum up
or you know that was a question how we
should use that data so we we use the
total score we we've done a whole range
of analysis on that and we'll we'll uh
write a paper as well on the more events
but basically it's 25 different items
for different sort of typical war events
that happen and we ask that the child
about that as well as the caregiver we
asked the child about the more exposure
the war invented experience but also the
caregiver about the war events the child
experienced and we combined the two so
it's a pretty solid measure of war
events
there's still a lot of issues with that
by the way but i i don't think i can go
into that now
the mental health so
caregivers knew
a little bit about this study from the
recruitment process but they didn't know
about
the specific mental health disorders
when we asked about them so we just
asked the questions they didn't have to
complete the questionnaire themselves
they were asked in interviews so if they
had questions they could always ask the
interviewer for clarifications
and these are all established mental
health measures and then obviously we
created cut-offs based on clinical
interviews
okay the next slide is just one example
of looking at bi-directional
relationships because we have
longitudinal data here and this is the
example of caregiver depression and
child symptoms so the child symptoms
here are
standardized and summed across the three
um
mental health outcomes so this this is a
continuous measure of mental health
and importantly um
we would expect
the child
that caregiver depression
might
increase the child mental health
symptoms right
but what we also find is that the child
symptoms the child mental health
symptoms over time has an impact on
caregiver depression
and that actually we find for quite a
few of those risk factors
so
it's not just the environment that has
an impact on the child but it's also the
child that has an impact on the
environment and i think that's a very
important aspect as well to consider for
interventions and i'll come back to that
and implications
let me move on to the biology
and with the biology i'll go a bit
quicker um i could say much about that
but um
i'll summarize those finer scenes a
little bit more succinctly
so we wanted to look here so we still at
the beginning of looking at the
biological data uh kovit
shut down the labs in london which meant
there's a long time that we couldn't
actually get to our samples
but everything is analyzed now i mean
everything is genotyped and everything
is ready for analysis so we've looked at
the hair cortisol in relation to ptsd
and walls so we wanted to know where the
hair could it all reflects the exposure
to wall
we also want to look at whether hair
cortisol is associated with ptsd in
children so all of this is in children
and then
we've done some work on the role of
epigenetics in psychological resilience
and that reflects work by my post doctor
melissa smith
and so first question we looked at war
exposure and cortisol
and we did find associations but
they were not very robust when we
included age of the children
that correlation was no longer
significant
what we then did we looked at the
association between war events and
cortisol in depending on the age of
exposure of the children
and what we found was really interesting
in that there was an association but
only in children that were in their
adolescent years during the exposure to
war suggesting that adolescence is a
sort of
sensitive period or critical period
for
longer lasting biological embedding of
war exposure
so that was only in that group
that were older than 12 years
we then looked at ptsd and we found that
there was a
robust association between ptsd and
cortisol
even when controlling for all the
covariates and we we've we have a lot of
covariates and we control for all of
them
in the next step we look at the
mediating effects
we wanted to see whether war exposure
whether cortisol or ptsd mediates
the effects of war exposure
and what we found is that there is a
partial mediation
between of the effect of war explosion
cortisol by ptsd
when we ran the opposite
testing where the cortisol was mediating
effects between war and ptsd
there was also a partial mediation but
it was a lot less so it seems the case
that
war
leads to elevated hair cortisol
particularly in those children that
develop ptsd in relation to the war
exposure
and i'll leave it at that
i know that's not very much but
basically
so
the the distance between war exposure
and the measurement of cortisol is
between
two to four years in our sample
right so that's quite a long distance
from the initial exposure
and that was particularly the case in
children that were in the adolescent
years during the war explosion
and i just want to mention
for the role of epigenetics
we actually haven't analyzed the data
yet but what we've done we've developed
the theoretical framework
that we will use to look at epigenetics
and
to take into account genetic factors
because genetic factors act upon the
epigenome or dna methylation but they
might also be stable methylation
over time and then obviously there are
protective
factors and adverse
adversity that together then result in
epigenetic
signatures that are associated with
resilience
um
there's a lot more to be said about that
but i don't we don't have any analysis
yet but this is basically the framework
that we're going to use i'm happy to
share that paper with anyone that's
interested in having a closer look at
that
but let me move on to the treatment of
syrian refugee children
and
how to do that over telephone
we thought that was a really innovative
thing to do
and then kovic 19 hit and suddenly the
whole world was doing uh treatment over
the telephone but actually when i was
thinking about that idea and i spoke to
several people in the field before covid
most people said no we don't really do
that in those settings and no one was
you know even thinking about doing that
in the future
but why could it be important well
we know that children
that experience war at a higher risk for
development of mental health problems
but also that many don't ex and don't
receive treatment and that's for a range
of reasons it's
often
very difficult to
set up new services in those settings
it's difficult to recruit qualified
staff
and refugees are often not mobile they
can't just go to a clinic that easily
so we wanted to
adapt an existing
treatment for delivery over telephone
with the help of trained and supervised
lay counsellors
and then we wanted to evaluate the
feasibility acceptability and efficacy
of this new treatment with syrian
refugee children in lebanon and we were
using that
we basically uh
using the biopath study
to recruit people into our clinical
trial and and basically these are all
the children all the families that said
they would like help
if they met inclusion criteria for a
clinical trial they were offered
inclusion in the clinical trial if not
they were receiving other treatment we
had several psychologists working on
counsellors working with us so we
provided free treatment to every single
person that was associated affiliated
with the family that participated in the
study
so this is basically the biopath sample
the intervention is sita common elements
treatment approach
and this is a modular trans-diagnostic
therapy developed for those kind of
settings
and is based on the most effective
cognitive behavioral therapy components
we first developed the t-seater manual
by delivering sita face-to-face
and some piloting and then we run a
randomized control trial which ended up
being very small
to evaluate the feasibility
acceptability and efficacy
the measures that we used
were
the same mental health symptom scales
that i we used uh for the rest of the
biopath study we used it's the same
clinical interview
um in addition we had in-session
assessments that was the client
monitoring form which is part of the
treatment so every session the counselor
is completing a short assessment of the
child
uh also the cyclops was used at the
beginning and the last session as well
in the middle
and then we also
completed some qualitative research so
we interviewed the councillors that
delivered t-seater and we interviewed 11
families that received t-seaters so both
the child as well as the caregiver
we ended up with a very small sample
in our rct it was very difficult
recruiting children and families into
this study
actually
from all the children that initially and
families that initially expressed an
interest
only seven percent ended up receiving
treatment even though that treatment was
overflown
because we end up with a very small
sample of about 20 children so 10 in the
treatment and turning the control
condition the control condition was
treatment as usual
we used the bayesian analysis approach
to help us with that and we were able to
show that
there are
significant
treatment effects of the t seated
condition
with a moderate effect size of about
point thirty three it's harder to
interrupt i mean do you mind saying a
little bit about why you think the
take-up was so low i mean it seems this
is a very vulnerable population
uh other security concerns
um they don't agree with intervention
yeah it would be great to do yes so we
we actually have conducted a qualitative
study exactly on that
and
to some degree
when they were asked to
attend the intake session which was in
the clinic
the intake session was in the clinic the
treatment was over phone or in the
clinic depending on what they were
randomized into
um
quite a few parents thought they no
longer have a the children no longer
have a problem or it's not actually not
too bad
i think there were work commitments that
getting they were getting in the in the
way
of the work commitments of the child or
of the caregiver transport issues
uh so quite a few logistic problems
but also
um i would say um
a limited understanding of mental health
problems that need treatment
so these were some of the points that
came up
but we we're still working on the
analysis of that data
michael that's a really interesting
observation actually but uh i'm just
flagging that we have seven minutes left
so yes
yes
thank you i will i will get through
um
some the the positive effects of the
treatment was mostly driven by the
reduction in depression symptoms
then we also looked at the in-session
assessment and you can see here with the
client monitoring form that there is
really a very
steep decrease over time in all the
children that receive treatment
that was also shown in the cyclops which
measures problems functioning well-being
so it was high baseline and then
significantly reduced towards the the
final session and these changes were
significant
the qualitative findings i could say a
lot about that but i'll keep that really
short so we looked at the feasibility by
interviewing the councillors
three themes emerged basically
they found that
that delivering therapy over the phone
solves some problems but it also creates
some additional practical and logistical
challenges such as
bad connections with the phones or
finding a space where the child could
speak without being heard by others
they
generally found that the t seater was
adapted well to
overcome cultural blocks
and that tcta works
and is needed to some
to some degree they were surprised that
it worked as well as it did i think some
of the counselors were quite um
skeptical whether this would work
but generally they found that it would
work
when we interviewed the caregivers and
the children four themes emerged
actually quite similar again that it
solves some problems but also creates
some challenges
that tcita works for most families but
there are some challenges that remain in
other families that can't be solved
easily because the the challenging
context remains a challenging context
another factor was that the relationship
between the council and the child and
caregiver was very important and that
the family's attitude to mental health
was also
very important
important to mention
this intervention was not just focusing
on the individual child but those there
was also parenting component to it so
caregivers were involved in it
so let me in the last few minutes
uh discuss
what we found so basically we found
mental health problems are frequent
every second child reports significant
problems
25.6 percent of caregivers
when asked said they would like to
receive treatment for their child so
that suggests there is a significant
perceived need for mental health
services and also willingness to use
them
however the majority of these children
never receive treatment and that is to
various barriers
we found that about 20 of the sample met
our criteria for resilience
that is a lot less than in other studies
and the reason it's a lot less is
because we defined resilience as being
below the cutoffs of multiple dimensions
of mental health outcomes
if we would have looked at only a ptsd
and considered anyone that is below the
cutter for ptsd resilience our
resilience
proportion would be much more similar to
previous studies but it's really
important to look at across multiple
dimensions
and we identified a range of factors
that are associated with risk and
resilience
we ex
found that war exposure and mental
health problems are associated with
biological factors and that biological
embedding seems to be particularly in
those
children the case that were exposed
during adolescence
we successfully adapted
a treatment to be delivered over
telephone
uh children allocated to tc there's a
telephone delivered seat is
significantly improved over time but the
randomized controlled trial was very
small and findings need to be replicated
in larger studies but the qualitative
research
suggests that
both counsellors and families that
received help
found the treatment effective
but tisita may not be a solution that
works for in every situation and every
family and i want to end with some of
the implications the main implications
of this
is that many refugee children suffer
from significant mental health problems
we know that
but that number is actually quite high
and most of these children never receive
treatment and even when we offer them
treatment over the phone most of them
don't receive treatment and actually
quite a few children that receive
treatment drop out of treatment we had a
lot less drop out in the phone condition
but with
traditional
services many children will drop out
we've identified several predictors that
point to the family and the wider social
context as particularly relevant and
this means interventions should focus
not just on the individual but also
their social context so systemic
approaches are particularly important as
well as the mental health of the
caregiver is it very important we need
to treat the caregivers mental health in
order to help the child
so standard delivery of treatment and
programs that are usually delivered in
clinics
is unlikely to reach children in need
treatment over phone will overcome some
of those barriers but not will be not
sufficient will be not will not be
sufficient
i think what is really needed is
community-based approaches that involve
community members and that reach not
only the child but also the social
context the caregivers that will be
absolutely crucial to reach more
children and to overcome this treatment
gap
just an acknowledgement of my research
partners of the various funding that we
received
and i thank you very much for your
attention
thank you very much
michael thank you very much for
threading
all these
disciplines through epigenetics
psychology
community-based programming
um thank you very much indeed um
[Music]
when i say your last slide i say you
need an anthropologist on your team but
most importantly uh you know maybe you
could just say a few words on your local
partners because community-based
approaches are spearheaded by local
partners could you just tell us a little
bit about that and then if there are the
questions please raise your hand and put
them in the chat i know there was just a
detailed question on the seat approach
uh how many sessions and over what time
was that provided to
people to accept but i'd really like to
ask you a quick question on on
on how local partners
took this together not just the people
who were implementing uh in the field
but how they co-designed perhaps or
co-implemented
or
see
the future directions of your work
yeah so this is this is future
directions we
uh are working on developing a
community-based approach based on
our experience in in lebanon and we in
order to
increase the recruitment into the
randomized controlled trial we've been
running sessions in the settlements
and those have been very helpful
and that's really sort of where we felt
that we really have to do something in
the settlements
because for them to leave
for refugee families especially many
many of those have many children so if
one child has a problem what do they do
with all the other children that's an
issue
and so that makes them much more
less much less likely to actually uh
seek services even if they're provided
not too far from the settlement
because it's difficult to get there so
um yeah delivering services
right in the settlements is what they
told us would they would like but also
there's some stigma issues they wouldn't
like that other people know
that they receive treatments that was
more problem more a problem in some
settlements less in other settlements so
there was quite a bit of
variability between settlements but we
found
that they actually were very engaged so
we went i was
we designed the sessions we went with
our local staff into those settlements
and delivered those sessions well i
didn't deliver them but my uh field
staff delivered them in arabic and we we
had
large groups uh joining in these
discussions and very lively discussions
and it was actually quite helpful to
identify
families that really are worried about
their child because they there is a
significant problem whereas there were
quite a few that thought you know a
treatment may be you know interesting
but they don't necessarily didn't see
a clear
need
i think a big part of that would be
psycho education to inform them
about
the problems that we typically see in
children and at what level do they need
treatment but also
i think an important aspect would be to
maybe
deliver some sessions on resilience and
what promotes resilience and
families strengthening the families and
parenting so that's what i would do
what i think would be very crucial is to
recruit
community members from those settlements
to actually deliver some of that or
co-deliver that and co-create it i think
that's absolutely key
thank you
are there any quick questions
most of our participants say thank you
for a great talk but have to go at uh at
this cut-off point um
before before nightfall
this is winter
i'm just checking but mostly thank you
very much indeed michael that was a
really great uh presentation
i'm actually going to ask you one more
question i'm sorry i'm really interested
in this because in the middle east and
country context gender is a big
dimension so we know that ptsd is
different across gender and maybe that i
know you probably treated that as a
covariate rather than anything else but
you have any any
uh last thoughts on the gender dimension
of your work
interestingly the caregivers were
mothers right do you have any
yes
so we looked at the the prevalence rate
separately between
uh boys and girls
and externalizing problems as you can
imagine are more prevalent amongst boys
and depression war amongst girls so
there are some some differences
um
i would i don't remember regarding war
exposure
whether there's some difference i could
imagine that the boys are more likely to
experience more exposure because they're
more likely to be outside than the girls
um
i think that's also the case in the
settlements some of the families that
that i visited
i it seemed that the children are mostly
within
the the tent or within the content they
were living in whereas in other families
the children were just basically outside
all the time by themselves
so
it could vary quite a bit between
different families
yeah anyway thank you very much for
that big picture
for the very careful detailed
analysis of
people in need and it was a pleasure
to have you talk to us at yale and thank
you very much
welcome thanks for watching yeah thanks
for inviting me and thanks for the
patience i i realized there's a lot
uh of findings but i'm excited about all
our findings so i sort of wanted to
share what we have at this stage and
there's obviously
there's there's lots more to be done
with the data and if anyone is
interested
uh to collaborate please get in touch
with me and it might that might be
possibility
well yours is a landmark study so thank
you very much indeed take good care
you're welcome take care